Oh
I once asked a seemingly confident man
what his biggest insecurity or fear was
to my surprise he answered falling in
love right now
he said he feared love because his
number-one priority was to maintain a
concentrated mentality focused to better
himself academically career-wise and
altogether you may say this is an excuse
to not fall in love but new research
indicates that this man's reasoning
might actually be accurate a study was
conducted by researcher Hank Van
Steenburgen along with colleagues from
leading University and the University of
Maryland on 43 participants who were in
new relationships meaning six months or
less they were asked to perform specific
tasks such as separating relevant and
irrelevant information the results the
participants ability to concentrate and
form tasks were not present Steenburgen
shared in his study high levels of
passionate love of individuals in the
early stage of a romantic relationship
are associated with reduced cognitive
control also adding it could be that the
obsessive nature of passionate love
imposes important constants on
performing well in tasks that require
self-control ray padilha Frank or author
of the book free fall a late-in-life
love affair felt extremely
head-over-heels for her current mate
regardless of how emotionally ecstatic
she was the newfound love took a
terrible toll on her health she noted
becoming lightheaded losing weight not
being able to fall asleep for days or
being able to concentrate her eat I was
happier than ever emotionally even
though I couldn't eat and felt shaky all
the time called Frank or Frank or lost
15 pounds almost immediately and her
friends were concerned one of her
friends recalls her saying during an
outing at lunch she's ordering
everything on the menu and I won't have
anything because I can't even swallow
psychologist Dorothy Kenneth called this
limerence the obsessive intrusive and
all-consuming state we're in where we
justify letting work friends
responsibilities even ourselves slide so
we can satisfy our overly enthusiastic
need for our new partner
Jennifer Nelson of today.com says you
lose your concentration you may think
very clearly but you can't think about
anything but him or her
it's the dopamine that gives you that
obsessive focus romantic love is just an
obsession you're focused just not on
work or your to-do list have you ever
found yourself in love and incapable of
concentrating on other responsibilities
or would you say you have the capability
of balancing out everything very well
let us know your thoughts in the
comments below as always if you like
this video be sure to subscribe to see
the latest videos from Psych to go thank
you for watching